it's definitely weighing on me to figure
out what to do tris and i are in a way
better place than we were before
but i'm still trying to navigate my way
through my feelings
and i don't know if i've really had time
to think about what moving would mean
for our relationship
will she or won't she move to boston
that's the question fans of keeping up
with the kardashians are asking about
khloe kardashian
leading up to the series finale i'm
gonna figure it all out i promise you
the hit reality show is coming to an end
after 20 seasons
and one of the big questions still
lingering is what's going on between
coco and tristan thompson
tune in because you never know what's
going to happen in a sneak peek at
keeping up
the good american founder films a video
for a time capsule that she and her
famous family are making to commemorate
the show's
end and khloe reveals what she hopes her
life looks like in the future
what are some of the things you hope
happened to you in the next
15 to 20 years i hope i have a sibling
for true
but also i don't feel incomplete if i
don't
i don't know i think i want to be
married again i think
but i also don't think i need to be
married in order to feel
like this is our union of course chloe
and tristan split
in february 2019 amid his cheating
scandal with kylie jenner's former
bestie jordan woods
you know things happen and of course i'm
sorry and apologetic as much as i can be
at the time chloe opened up to et about
being content with her single status
and spending her time and energy on
their now three-year-old daughter true
you guys have been through so much in
your life but what are you what are you
looking for now you're not looking
i'm not but i'm not like inten i'm just
super happy and content and i'm focused
on
work and like taking care of me my body
and soul and
true and i just i'm having so much fun
with her
and when i want to i will it's not some
deliberate thing that i think that hard
about
but all that changed after the pandemic
hit
the two reconnected and focused on
co-parenting little true
i think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style
but it's a beautiful thing to get along
with each other and for your kids to see
that
and back in march chloe revealed that
she and tristan have made embryos
it's such a blessing we have all this
modern science and technology and
everything we have available to us but
it's still been a really strange
way to go about it now chloe is faced
with the decision to move from los
angeles to boston to be with the nba
star
whose contract was picked up by the
boston celtics
how's boston it's good i mean
the weather's been great everyone's been
welcoming it makes me happy
so i know that the holidays are coming
up
there's so many things to discuss that
we've discussed i think it works perfect
i have a game on christmas
in boston okay it makes sense for all
due christmas
in boston but you should be out here but
if you're losing on by next friday
i don't know i have to just think about
it we should
worry about it fans will just have to
tune into the series finale to see how
it all goes down
but one thing's for sure chloe is all
about adapting
something she opened up about to eat tea
back in 2019.
i think working on your personal growth
internally is something that will be a
forever
mission and i always want to evolve and
grow and mature
emotionally because that's how we become
better
people while the world is changing
around us we should adapt to that too
but always remember to be
kind and just courteous of what's
happening around you too so i don't ever
want that to change
[Music]